hey guys how's it go it's Justine and
today is a very long overdue video today
I'm gonna go through all of the updated
gear that I use to shoot my youtube
videos before we get started if you're a
beginner this was nothing that I would
have ever been able to get when I first
started making YouTube videos well I
first started making YouTube videos I
was using the iSight camera that was
built into my macbook and guess what it
worked for me I get the question all the
time about what vlogging cameras do I
use and it's changed so much throughout
the years because I used to be all 100%
Canon and I was such a huge canon fan I
still am a Canon fan but unfortunately
they've kind of dropped the ball as far
as consumer 4k cameras go they currently
don't have something on the market that
is this small and compact that does 4k
and I just recently did a video about
this this is the Sony rx100 Mark 5
there's a many renditions of this
particular camera but this is the first
one that I have ever had in the series
the best part about this is it does 4k
it also does 120 frames a second so if
you do like to shoot slow-mo videos and
you don't want to lug around all of this
stuff this is the way to go you can also
shoot in various picture profiles so if
you plan on doing any sort of color
grading shooting with those profiles
will allow you to do that so this is the
camera that I would use on a day-to-day
basis because it's small I can throw it
in my purse it's quite versatile but
this does not have an audio input and
that drives me absolutely crazy because
I'm so particular about audio and
sometimes when I'm editing and there's
audio pops and there's a lot of white
noise it drives me absolutely crazy but
I'd already shot the video and since I'm
shooting these videos by myself I can't
really monitor the audio so I just gotta
cross my fingers and hope for the best
I always keep this with me even if I
have one of these other cameras I'm sure
after this you guys don't have a ton a
question so hopefully if you have any of
those you can leave those in the
comments below and if I can't answer it
hopefully that somebody else in the
comments can help answer it for you so
what we've got going on here I'm filming
right now with a sony a7s mark 2 which
is this camera I do have two of these
mostly because when I shoot my cooking
videos I love to have the same camera so
that everything kind of matches up and
it looks very even so when I shoot the
Far Away shots this is the lens that I
use this is a 35 Prime and it is
absolutely beautiful so this is the 35
millimeter Prime and this is how far
away I have to be to get myself in frame
so when vlogging with this lens it's
nearly impossible because I'd be like
this
that's not gonna work out so well but
this lens is incredible I do a lot of
close up shots with this camera and this
lens so a lot of times if you see me
looking off to the side I'm looking off
to this camera and trying to get a
close-up shot we don't have two cameras
today because I'm showing you this
camera what I love about this is it's
incredibly large sensors you can also
get really great shots at night in
low-light situations this used to be the
camera that I would vlog with I would
actually take this around with huge
lenses microphones and it was just so
tedious and heavy and crazy and I was
like what am i doing and I had this
realization because this is a very
expensive camera and I made a really big
mistake Justine did you just drop your
camera in there last year when I was on
vacation with my family I dropped this
by accident into a pool and I had just
bought my second camera so that I would
be able to up my game as far as the
cooking videos go oh my heart hurts that
camera is so expensive but fell right
into the pool and it was like this is a
way too expensive a mistake to make so I
was trying to figure out what is an
alternative solution to not carrying
around than a 7s mark too but still be
able to get sort of that same type of
quality at the time there was another
option it was the sony a6300 but there
were a bunch of people who were
complaining because they said that it
overheated when you shot in 4k for too
long and that's where this guy came into
play this is the sony a 65 hundred and
the biggest difference between this and
the a7 s as this uses full-frame lenses
and this one does not the sensor on this
is so much smaller than this one I'll
give you guys a side-by-side comparison
so what the bigger sensor you're able to
get better low-light photos and videos
and it's crazy after using this one so
much and then switching my lenses I'm
like man this is insane
you guys can see what I'm talking about
as far as the sensor sizes so the bigger
the sensor the
light that is allowed into this camera
you make precious another lens that I
like to use so this is the lens that I
used to use to vlog with all the time
this is a 16 into a 35 so the 16 allowed
me to still get a nice wide angle view
and I can still zoom in a little bit to
the 35 the one that I'm using right now
is a 24 to 70 I don't like this lens a
lot but it's not the best for vlogging
because it still isn't that wide-angle
views so this is the 24 to 70 let me
give you what it looks like without
being zoomed in and out let's zoom all
the way in so having that 16 is perfect
this is the 16 to 35 and I loved this so
much because it is very wide angle yet
it will do a little bit of zoom as you
can see you there one of the other
reasons that I switched to the a 6500 is
it's a lot smaller sometimes I do miss
having the a7s2 when I'm out vlogging
especially in low-light situations but
the ease of use for this in comparison
to this I can use smaller lenses which
are much lighter like this is a 16 to 70
which is pretty crazy this is the 16 to
70 and this lens is so great but clearly
it's not the best for close-up vlogging
but what is great about it is the zoom
[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of the vlogs I do shoot with this
if I'm not carrying around this if I'm
not able to switch lenses and I'm gonna
be in a situation like an event that I'm
not able to switch out to this one this
is a much more wide-angle lens but I
also don't get a lot of zoom this is at
10 2 and 18 so the 10 it gives a much
wider field of view which is my favorite
look when vlogging and because it's such
a wide angle now I'm using the 10 to 18
lens on and the a 6500 and as you guys
can see it's a very nice wide angle but
I can also zoom in just a little bit and
he's off I usually don't have to worry
about things not being in focus because
the biggest downside of these cameras is
the screens they do not have flip out
the screen like what is this come on
ah just flip to the side what are you
doing all of that taken into
consideration though my tip if you're
vlogging without a screen is when you
lightly touch the shutter button so if
I'm vlogging like this I'll lightly
touch that I don't usually help to get
me into focus quicker so I can just go
about my shooting and hopefully fingers
crossed I'm in focus and there's plenty
of times especially on this lens that
it's not always quite in focus but you
just gotta roll with it like what am I
gonna do I can't reshoot something that
I shot and what's done is done
like I was saying about this lens it's
much lighter at the size comparison
that's a big difference and the weight
way lighter this is the 2.8 18
millimeter and this is the vlogging lens
that I use the only problem is it's
fixed so whatever you see here there's
no zoom this is it but if I was holding
the camera you guys would be about this
far away and all the way back here it's
what you see have you guys connected to
my iPhone so I can see what I'm shooting
this is working out great so what I'm
blogging I like to use this little
Manfrotto tripod it's small its compact
I know a lot of people love using the
jovi tripods but I'm not the biggest fan
of those I
and but I feel like they're not that
sturdy so what I like about this is it's
pretty sturdy even though this is the
tripod that I was using that it when I
camera fall in the pool but we don't
talk about that this also has a pretty
smooth pan so when you push this in a
lot of times you'll see some of my shots
where there's like a nice smooth pan I'm
just holding that in and going like that
and panning absolutely off to use the
audio cuz that's loud
speaking of audio definitely something
that's very important apologies if I'm
jumping around I'm not very good at
organizing my thoughts I'm just kind of
talking as I think of something so right
now we're gonna discuss microphone this
is a fairly new purchase for me I bought
this a few months ago when I was in New
York this is phantom powered which means
it takes power from the camera so you
don't need any other batteries
you don't need another cord to plug into
the camera it just works
it also has these little left and right
microphones so if you want to shoot in
stereo you can but they also move so if
you're doing some sort of an interview
or something you could point one here or
one there or you know like if you get
the point and put on its little you
little microphone song let me see that
baby 860 500 is also a touchscreen which
is nice but I turned it off I felt like
I kept hitting buttons when I didn't
mean to if it's also shoots in hundred
twenty frames so you can get some super
cool slow-mo shots and for me going
between these two cameras I really was
not able to tell that big of a
difference because a lot of the times
since I am on the go nothing like I film
on auto a lot there's just no time to be
messing around with settings you just
kind of have to again and cross your
fingers hope for the best and then when
you're in editing you're kicking
yourself because you're like man why
didn't I do this this is one of the goal
mics this is what I used to use before I
use this so the problem with this that I
found when I switched over to the a 6500
is it was so close it was actually
getting in my shots what I love about
the go microphone is it's a lot less
expensive than any of the other rode
microphones you also don't need a
battery so it just powers itself from
the camera but you do need an audio
input which sometimes can also cause
trouble because I'll forget to plug it
in from this is this rode microphone
this one is really nice because feels a
little more sturdy but it will give you
a much better sound it does need a
9-volt
which is always quite unfortunate
because guess what the battery's dead
can you know what no one ever has a
9-volt battery this just plugs in right
to the side but this little guy seems to
have solved all of that the audio and
this is a little bit better than this
but what I'm doing is side by side
comparison it's it's you really can't
tell unless you're listening for it you
might be wondering what I'm filming with
like I said if a 7s2 with this little
setup is kind of unique because I have
one of the small HD cameras on this
little tripod thing that has two mounts
so one for my camera and one for the
small HD screen and I'm using Sennheiser
wireless microphones that are connected
to a sony XLR input which is also
phantom power lock your XLR input in
from this current microphone that I have
right here that actually came with this
set and then in the second input I have
the Sennheiser wireless microphones
plugged in as well so that's the current
set up here that I usually use at my
unboxing desk so these small HD monitors
are incredible and you really do need
something to be able to see what you're
doing especially if you're shooting by
yourself because how are you supposed to
know these are great they come in many
different sizes there are various price
ranges depending upon how bright you
want the screen the resolution how large
the screen is and what you plan on doing
so I'll put all those links in the
description below so everything that I
talked about will be down there so you
guys can check it out SD cards I've been
using these Lexar ones mostly because it
was the only thing available on Amazon
Prime now and I was desperate for SD
cards so I was able to get a bunch of
them within 15 minutes on Amazon these
are only 128 but you like to see mine on
you get a bigger card well first of all
that's the only size that they had and
two when I'm shooting I kind of like to
have a backup of if I'm shooting a bunch
of videos I'll take those SD cards out
after I've shot like four videos set
them aside do not touch them and start
shooting on different cards so I just
know that that footage is safe there's
no chance of me deleting it and Leslie
those SD cards which I've definitely
done before it's quite a process people
think this is very easy and I wish that
it was I wish that I could say that
everything is just magic but it takes a
lot of time to edit some of my cooking
videos can take me anywhere from 15 to
20 hours to edit and even then when I'm
done I still don't feel like I'm done
there's so many more things that I could
do as far as color correction and music
and graphic
but I just kind of run out of time so
unless I have somebody full-time helping
me do all of this I kind of just have to
say alright and that's enough you're
done now interesting one of the
downsides to these Sony cameras is the
batteries die super quick so my biggest
recommendation is if you do use any of
these you'll clearly figure that out
very quickly that extra batteries are a
must and constantly carrying around
extra batteries and chargers but the
good thing is you can charge this via
micro USB so the RL and you're desperate
you can always do that so this has been
a lifesaver one of the most difficult
things especially when editing 4k
footage or managing large files and
trying to edit is how fast is your hard
drive this is a little teeny tiny
solid-state drive and I have been using
this for a couple of months my friend
Sara DG and my friend Nathan who also
helps me shoot at times they both
recommended this and it is pretty much
saved me so much time they currently
only go up to 2 terabytes so I have two
of these that I kind of bounce back and
forth between footage so I'll do a shoot
copy the footage here take that footage
and then back it up to another drive
just in case something happens and it's
something that I'm really worried about
losing and it was a very big videos lots
of time commitment especially sponsored
videos how that goes up to a third Drive
but this little guy has been great I
mean look how small this is 2 terabytes
solid-state fragments 2 terabytes does
not get me very far I probably have like
two videos on this two videos meaning
all of the files that go into creating
two videos a little case is super cute
that I've been using for my SD cards I
felt like I was so unorganized I just
had SD cards everywhere and there is not
a central home for them although I am
missing some because this used to be all
full so this is also the latest GoPro
Hero 5 I used to shoot a lot more with
my GoPro but I really have been doing
anything that crazy but I love this
little guy it's super cute and the best
part about it is it's already waterproof
so you don't have to have another case
over top of it to make it waterproof the
audio one this one I feel like is not as
good as the previous version which is
why I still used to love using the Hero
4 since this is already waterproof I
think that's probably the reason why the
audio isn't that great it's not bad by
any means it's just not as good as the 4
was without a case on it
last but not least cell phones cell
phone video now has gotten so incredibly
good that if you hold it up side by side
leave the Samsung or the iPhone up to
one of these it is really hard to
distinguish which is which which is a
really great problem because sometimes
when I'm filming I do still after all
these years kind of get embarrassed
pulling this out at the mall
it just feels super invasive there's
just a very nice familiar feeling when
you just flip that front-facing camera
and you're talking to your phone maybe
for me because I feel like I did that
for so long but it's something that is
so easy to do it still looks good I hope
this was somewhat helpful for you guys
it's a lot of things but I think my
biggest advice to you guys if you want
to start I don't want you to be
intimidated by this video at all because
you don't need all of this stuff to
start all you need is yourself camera
and if you don't have a camera you have
a phone you can edit you could upload
you can basically do everything from the
palm of your hand well hopefully as as
far as you guys to go out there and get
creating whatever it is that you're
passionate about go out make a video and
have fun doing it well thank you guys
for watching I'll put links in the
description to everything that I talked
about today I don't even touch on drones
but I feel like you guys you get the
point I've got it off your own videos
but you guys know what I use this is
such a long overdue video because I get
so many questions and people say oh I
just bought that camera that you
recommend it was like I recommended that
years ago I gotta do an update I'm
loving you guys down so that being said
I will see you guys later because now I
have to go edit this video
[Music]
[Applause]